And so she headed off to make it as its very own podcast, its own show, with her co-workers at Serial Productions and the New York Times. And the show is now finished. It just launched this week. I'm thrilled that we can present the first episode of their show here on our show, and that is what we're going to do today. It's great, and without further delay, let's just get into it. Here's Susan.
于是，她决定将其制作成一档独立的播客节目，与 Serial Productions 和《纽约时报》的同事们共同打造。现在节目已经完结了，就在本周刚刚上线。我很高兴我们能在这里展示他们节目的第一集，这正是我们今天要做的。这很棒，废话不多说，让我们直接进入正题。有请苏珊。
The women are seeking fertility treatment for a variety of reasons. They've had a couple of miscarriages, and they're pushing 40. They don't have fallopian tubes, or they need sperm. One woman has a diagnosis that's like a metaphor from feminist sci-fi, a uterus with a single horn like a unicorn.
女性寻求生育治疗的原因各不相同。有的因为多次流产，且年纪已近40岁；有的因为没有输卵管，或者需要捐赠的精子。其中一位女性的诊断结果听起来就像女性主义科幻小说里的隐喻：一个像独角兽一样只有一个角的子宫。
All of them line up at the fertility clinic at Yale University.
她们都在耶鲁大学的生育诊所排队。
A couple of the women choose this clinic because they work at Yale, and that's what the Yale health plan covers. Others go to Yale on the recommendation of their doctors. But in Connecticut, you don't even really need the recommendation. Yale Medicine-- it's a blue chip medical brand.
其中一些女性选择这家诊所是因为她们在耶鲁工作，而耶鲁的健康计划涵盖了这里。其他人则是通过医生的推荐来到耶鲁。但在康涅狄格州，你甚至不需要推荐。耶鲁医学是一个蓝筹级的医疗品牌。
You know, Yale is just a huge name, and you just think anything that has anything to do with Yale is going to be the best of the best.
你知道，耶鲁的名气很大，你只会觉得任何与耶鲁有关的事情都是最好的。
It's really not close to our house. It's not where I would have gone. But we figured, another doctor from another hospital said this is the best you can get. And of course, you want that.
它离我们家其实并不近。如果不是因为另一家医院的医生说这是你能找到最好的选择，我可能不会去那里。当然，你总会想要最好的。
To some of the women, the clinic seems to live up to its billing. They like their doctors, feel cared for by them. That man is an angel, one of the women tells me. He is by far the best doctor I've ever had. Others are not happy at the clinic from the start. It's things like feeling like a number or issues with communication.
对一些女性来说，这家诊所似乎名副其实。她们喜欢自己的医生，感觉受到了照顾。其中一位女性告诉我：“那个男人简直是天使。他是我见过最好的医生。”其他人从一开始就不喜欢这家诊所。比如感觉自己只是个数字，或者沟通上存在问题。
There's a lot to communicate. You don't know how hard fertility treatment is until you get into it. And once you start it in one place, it can be difficult to go somewhere else. So they talk themselves into staying. That's the first thing they go against their instincts and talk themselves into.
需要沟通的事情非常多。你只有真正经历过，才知道生育治疗有多艰难。一旦你在某处开始了治疗，再想换地方就很困难了。所以她们说服自己留下来。这是她们违背直觉后，说服自己做的第一件事。
The women drive to the clinic before work in the morning for blood draws and then wait for the afternoon email from their nurse team. You really have to trust your nurse team, one of the women tells me. At this point, she did. The nurse team gives instructions, and the women give themselves shots. These shots contain hormones to stimulate the body to produce eggs. A side effect is emotional volatility.
女性们每天上班前开车去诊所抽血，然后等待护理团队下午发来的邮件。其中一位女性告诉我，你真的必须信任你的护理团队。当时，她是这么做的。护理团队给出指示，女性们自己注射药物。这些针剂含有刺激身体排卵的激素。副作用之一就是情绪波动。
The wind is making me cry, one of the women says. But the thing is, you have to stay calm. Don't get stressed. It's so stressful trying not to get stressed. One woman uses a fertility meditation app called Expectful. She does her guided meditation on the beach. The app plays the sound of waves while the real waves heave in the background. It's absurd, but so much of this is absurd, including the money. There's all kinds of stuff that's not covered, no matter what insurance you have.
“风吹得我想哭，”其中一位女性说。但问题是，你必须保持冷静。不要感到压力。试图不感到压力本身就是件压力巨大的事。一位女性使用了一款名为 Expectful 的生育冥想应用程序。她在海边做引导冥想。当真正的海浪在背景中翻腾时，应用程序播放着海浪的声音。这很荒谬，但生育治疗的很多环节都很荒谬，包括金钱。无论你有什么样的保险，各种各样的费用都不在承保范围内。
Meanwhile, your ovaries enlarge, and you get so bloated that your abdomen feels like bricks. And then finally, you get to the day you've been waiting for-- the day of the first egg retrieval, which is what it sounds like. The eggs are removed from the body and then fertilized or frozen, depending on what you're doing. How many eggs am I going to get? That is the big question. The more eggs you get, the better your chance of a healthy embryo, a viable pregnancy, a child.
与此同时，你的卵巢会增大，腹部肿胀得感觉像塞满了砖块。最后，终于到了你期待已久的日子——第一次取卵日，听起来就是它的字面意思。卵子从体内取出，然后根据你的计划进行受精或冷冻。我会取出多少颗卵子？这是个大问题。取出的卵子越多，获得健康胚胎、成功怀孕并拥有孩子的机会就越大。
The day of the retrieval, the women arrive at the clinic. They check in on different mornings in different months and calendar years. None of them are here on the same day, but they will come out of the day with the same story. Laura arrives for her retrieval on a weekday morning in January 2020. She checks in and changes into a gown.
取卵当天，女性们来到诊所。她们在不同月份、不同年份的不同早晨办理登记。没人会在同一天来到这里，但她们当天离开时都会有相同的故事。劳拉在2020年1月的一个工作日上午抵达诊所进行取卵。她办理登记并换上了手术服。
Two months ago, Laura was diagnosed with breast cancer. A double mastectomy followed, then an infection and additional surgeries. As soon as she freezes her eggs, she's going to start cancer treatment. It's a lot. Laura is trying to put all of that to the side and just focus on the procedure ahead.
两个月前，劳拉被诊断出患有乳腺癌。随后进行了双侧乳房切除术，接着又出现了感染，并进行了后续手术。一旦冷冻了卵子，她就要开始接受癌症治疗。这负担太重了。劳拉试图把所有这些抛在脑后，只专注于即将进行的手术。
I was excited, like trying to stay positive. And I was just like, having been through so much just the month prior, I was like, this is going to be easy because I had been through so many surgeries and procedures. I was just like, I know what this is like. I know what it's like to be under anesthesia or something and be given medication so you don't feel things.
我很兴奋，就像在努力保持积极一样。我当时心想，鉴于上个月刚经历了那么多，这次手术应该很简单，因为我已经经历过这么多手术和治疗了。我当时就想，我知道这是怎么回事。我知道麻醉或使用药物以致没有知觉是什么感觉。
The egg retrieval is a surgical procedure. A long needle is inserted into the vagina, then pierced through the vaginal wall and up into the ovary. Laura has been told in advance what drugs she will be getting during the procedure.
取卵是一项外科手术。医生会将一根长针插入阴道，穿过阴道壁，进入卵巢。劳拉提前被告知了手术过程中会使用的药物。
Two drugs, fentanyl, and another one, midazolam or -zalam. And I believe that one is to induce sleepiness.
“两种药物，芬太尼，还有另一种，咪达唑仑或者类似名字的药。我相信其中一种是用来诱导睡意的。”
Together, these two drugs offer what's often called moderate sedation. Basically, the fentanyl takes away pain, and the midazolam relaxes you. Some people get drowsy with this combination. Others remain alert. The use of fentanyl surprises some of the women. One of them, a public defender, has seen a lot of clients messed up by fentanyl, and for a second, she's worried. Another woman, Katie, a neuroscientist at Yale, feels a spark of interest.
这两种药合用通常被称为中度镇静。基本上，芬太尼止痛，咪达唑仑让你放松。有些人会因为这种组合感到昏昏欲睡，另一些人则保持清醒。芬太尼的使用让一些女性感到惊讶。其中一位是公设辩护人，她见过很多客户因为芬太尼而深受其害，所以有一瞬间她感到很担心。另一位女性，耶鲁大学的神经科学家凯蒂，则感到了一丝好奇。
And in fact, just being someone who studies addiction and studies some opioid use disorder, and as a curious person, I remember the morning of, thinking like, OK, this will be interesting. I've never tried fentanyl before. And so I expected to go in and have twilight anesthesia, not full anesthesia, but not feel anything.
“事实上，作为一个研究成瘾和阿片类药物使用障碍的人，出于好奇，我记得那天早上还在想，好吧，这会很有趣。我以前从没试过芬太尼。所以我预期会经历这种半梦半醒的麻醉，不是全麻，但应该什么都感觉不到。”
The women complete the last steps before the procedure, get an IV, go over some papers. If their partners came back with them, now their partners say goodbye. And then it's time. The women tell what happens next.
女性们完成了手术前的最后步骤，打上静脉点滴，处理了一些文件。如果伴侣陪同，现在就是告别的时候了。然后，时间到了。女性们讲述了接下来发生的事情。
I walked myself into the procedure room because you get rolled out afterwards. But you don't have any medication in you. You're just kind of hooked up to the IV pole. And I walked into there, and you get on the chair or table, whatever they call it. And that's from there. They said, you're not going to feel anything, and they explained everything that was going to happen.
“我自己走进手术室，因为术后会被推出来。但那时你还没用任何药物。只是连着静脉输液架。我走进去，坐上椅子或手术台，不管他们管那叫什么。然后他们说，你不会感觉到任何东西，并解释了即将发生的一切。”
They started the procedure, and I was just sort of taken by surprise, not expecting the excruciating pain, and just letting them know that I don't think the pain medication is doing anything. It really feels like you're stabbing the needle.
“手术开始时，我被惊到了，完全没想到会是钻心的疼痛，我告诉他们，我觉得止痛药一点作用都没有。那种感觉就像他们真的在拿针扎你。”
I felt everything. It's literally your most intimate parts of your body. They're using these long needles. And there's also a screen. So I can watch what they're doing, and I couldn't. I had to try and look away because literally each needle pierce, you feel.
“我感觉到了所有的一切。那真的是你身体最私密的部位。他们用的是长针。而且还有一个屏幕。所以我能看到他们在做什么，但我没法看。我不得不尝试转过头去，因为每一次针头穿刺，你都能感觉到。”
As we were moving along, it was my blood pressure started going up. I was sweating profusely and telling them, I was just in too much pain, that they had to stop. At that point, I remember them giving me more of the pain medication and me saying, it's not making a difference, a nurse coming over and putting a wet towel on my head, and another nurse holding my hand, and them comforting me and saying, you're going to be OK.
“手术进行时，我的血压开始升高。我汗如雨下，告诉他们我实在太疼了，必须停止。那一刻，我记得他们又给我用了更多的止痛药，但我说那根本没用。一位护士走过来，在我头上放了一条湿毛巾，另一位护士握住我的手安慰我说，你会没事的。”
The nurse who-- she was at the top of my body, kind of at my shoulders, wiping the tears away and helping me kind of hold my breath to keep myself still, so that the doctors didn't slip with the needle, and just telling me that I was going to be OK, that I was going to get through it.
“那位护士——她在我的上方，大约在肩膀位置，擦去我的眼泪，帮我憋住气以保持不动，这样医生就不会因为针头滑动而弄伤我，她一直告诉我我会没事的，我会熬过去的。”
And up until that moment, I'm so excited, like, oh I have 24 follicles. This is great. I'm going to have a great egg retrieval. And then you're like, oh, my god, I wish there was only one. Like, everything was counting on that retrieval. And that's how it feels, like the whole weight of your world. My partner and I, she's counting on me to be able to get through this and to have this successful retrieval. And all I'm feeling is, oh, my god, I need it to stop. Is this worth it?
“在那一刻之前，我非常兴奋，心想，哦，我有24个卵泡。太棒了。我的取卵效果会很好。然后你会觉得，哦天哪，我希望只有一个。好像一切都取决于这次取卵。那种感觉就像是全世界的重担都压在身上。我和我的伴侣，她指望我能挺过这一关，完成这次成功的取卵。但我感觉到的只有，天哪，我需要它停下来。这真的值得吗？”
And your feet are in the stirrups. And you're supposed to be laying on the table, but I remember tightening up and just trying to relax my body so that they could do what they needed to do because I was so tense that my bottom was almost off of the table.
“双脚放在脚架上。本来你应该躺在手术台上，但我记得我身体僵硬，试图放松以配合他们的操作，但我太紧张了，屁股几乎都离开了台面。”
I remember thrusting my hips up, actually thrusting my hips up, saying, I feel everything. And nobody believed me. And it's just like, I don't know. But what are you going to do? I wanted the procedure done. I just let it happen. And I was like, I'm awake, so.
“我记得我在顶胯，真的，我在奋力顶胯，我说，我什么都能感觉到。没人相信我。我不知道该怎么办。但你能做什么呢？我只想完成手术。我只能任由它进行。我当时想，反正我是清醒的。”
I was stone-cold sober and awake. And I remember, the egg retrieval, they kind of do them one by one or a couple at a time, my impression. And so you have moments in between pain to say, like, what the fuck is going on?
“我当时头脑完全清醒。我记得取卵是一个接一个或者几个一起进行的，这是我的印象。所以你在疼痛的间隙有一些时刻可以问，这到底是怎么回事？”
I do remember, I think I swore. I was using curse words because it was just so painful.
“我记得，我想我骂人了。我用了脏话，因为它实在太痛苦了。”
I don't know if I can do this any longer.
“我不知道我还能不能坚持下去。”
You just have to get through it. It's going to be over before you know it.
“你只能熬过去。很快就会结束的。”
OK, this is going to be over eventually.
“好吧，最终会结束的。”
You can do this. You can do this.
“你能做到的。你能做到的。”
You just want this moment to be over.
“你只希望这一刻快点结束。”
Get through it. Get through it.
“熬过去。熬过去。”
I remember yelling or kind of making like, ahh, and then really looking in confusion at my nurse, the attending nurse and her saying, I'm giving you the most I can legally give you.
“我记得我大叫或者发出了‘啊’的声音，然后困惑地看着我的护士，那位主管护士对我说，我已经给你用了法律允许范围内的最大剂量了。”
She said that that's the maximum that she's allowed to give me so she couldn't give me anything else.
“她说那是她被允许给我的最大剂量，所以不能再给我用任何药了。”
I'm almost certain that at one point, they said that they had given me all of the pain medication that they could give me.
“我几乎可以肯定，有一次他们说已经给我用了所有能用的止痛药。”
At one point, they did say that I had maxed out. I couldn't have any more fentanyl or Versed. And I was like, how is this possible?
“有一次，他们确实说我已经达到了极限。不能再用更多的芬太尼或咪达唑仑了。我心想，这怎么可能？”
How is that even-- like, how am I feeling this?
“这怎么可能……为什么我会有感觉？”
How do people go through this?
“人们是怎么熬过这一关的？”
I can feel that. I could feel the-- I don't even know how to describe that. You can just feel them inside of there. As a woman, we've all been through things with those kind of doctors and stuff, but this is just a pain, it's like hard to even explain what it felt like.
“我能感觉到。我能感觉到……我甚至不知道该怎么描述。你就是能感觉到他们在那里面。作为一个女性，我们都经历过类似这种医生的检查，但这次的疼痛，很难解释到底是什么感觉。”
It's-- this is hard to do, but could you describe the pain that you felt?
“这……很难描述，但你能描述一下你感受到的疼痛吗？”
Oh, gosh. It felt like someone was ripping something from the inside of your body.
“哦，天哪。感觉就像有人在从你体内深处撕扯什么东西。”
Yeah, which is literally what they were doing.
“是的，这字面上就是他们正在做的事情。”
That's what it felt like. Yeah.
“那种感觉就是那样。是的。”
Yeah, yeah. Ugh, I'm sorry.
“是啊，是啊。抱歉，我很难过。”
But I remember almost immediately thinking or almost daydreaming in that moment that the attending nurse had one tube going from my IV into my arm and another tube going from my IV into her pocket. Like, it occurred to me almost immediately that the nurse was stealing the fentanyl.
“但我记得当时几乎立刻产生了一个想法，或者说是白日梦，主管护士手里有一根管子从我的点滴袋连到我的手臂，另一根管子从我的点滴袋连到了她的口袋里。几乎是立刻，我就觉得那位护士在偷窃芬太尼。”
And I remember telling my friends after the procedure, my friends who were aware of what I was going through, but who are also colleagues at Yale in addiction research. I remember telling them like the nurse is stealing the fentanyl because it seems so obvious to me. I mean, fentanyl is the most diverted drug in medical settings. It's like a now major driver of the opioid crisis. And it was just really easy to imagine that someone with access to poorly controlled fentanyl would be abusing it.
“我记得手术后告诉我的朋友们，她们不仅知道我正在经历什么，而且也是耶鲁成瘾研究领域的同事。我记得告诉她们，护士在偷芬太尼，因为这对我来说太明显了。芬太尼是医疗环境中最容易被挪用的药物。它是现在阿片类药物危机的主要推手。很容易想象，有人有机会接触到监管不严的芬太尼，就会滥用它。”
That's so fascinating that that's the image that raised itself up for you because it is so evocative.
“这个画面在你脑海中浮现真是太令人震惊了，因为它太生动了。”
Because it is so evocative and also because it was true. A nurse at the clinic was stealing fentanyl. Not Katie's nurse, not the tube in the pocket, but a nurse at the clinic was stealing fentanyl and replacing it with saline. She did so undetected for months, which meant patients weren't getting fentanyl in their IVs. They were getting saltwater instead.
因为它确实生动，而且它是事实。诊所里的一位护士确实在偷窃芬太尼。不是凯蒂的那位护士，也不是管子伸进口袋的那位，但诊所里确实有一名护士在偷芬太尼，并用生理盐水代替。她数月未被发现，这意味着患者的静脉滴注中没有芬太尼，取而代之的是盐水。
Drug addicted former nurse is sentenced for a crime that caused unbearable pain to dozens of women. The nurse stole drugs and then replaced them with saline solutions.
染上毒瘾的前护士因导致数十名女性承受难以忍受的痛苦而被判刑。该护士偷走药物，然后用生理盐水替换。
Connecticut nurse admits that she swapped out anesthesia drugs for saltwater, causing excruciating pain to women during infertility treatments.
康涅狄格州护士承认她将麻醉药物换成了盐水，导致女性在不孕不育治疗期间承受了剧烈的痛苦。
It happened at a top rated center affiliated with--
这件事发生在一所顶级医疗中心，隶属于——
Tonight, a horrible story about the extremes a fertility nurse struggling with drug addiction took to get her fix.
今晚，一个关于一名深受毒瘾困扰的生育科护士为了获得毒品而不择手段的恐怖故事。
A federal investigation determined that as many as 200 patients may have been victims of this substitution over five months in 2020. Lawyers for some of the patients believe the real number is higher, and this went on for longer. I've talked to a dozen patients who believe they were victims of this. 11 of them are plaintiffs in a lawsuit against Yale, and their lawyers were present when we spoke.
联邦调查确定，2020年五个月内，可能多达200名患者是这种调包行为的受害者。一些患者的律师认为实际数字更高，而且持续的时间更长。我采访了十几位认为自己是受害者的患者。其中11人正在起诉耶鲁大学，我们交谈时她们的律师也在场。
When I started doing these interviews, I was struck by the echoes in these women's stories. To me, it sounded like a chorus of women saying, something is wrong here, again and again. The patients wondered how the clinic could have failed to detect this. And the conversations I was having made me wonder that, too.
当我开始做这些采访时，这些女性故事中的回响深深打动了我。对我来说，这听起来像是一群女性在反复呼喊：这里出问题了。患者们想知道为什么诊所一直没发现这一点。而我们的对话也让我产生了同样的疑问。
And then I began talking to other people, staffers who'd been there, and I learned about what went on behind the scenes. The staffers I spoke to were horrified by what the patients had experienced. They were grappling with their own questions about how this had happened, about what had gone amiss. The patients didn't know why they were in pain. Their doctors didn't know either.
然后我开始和曾在那里工作的人员交谈，我了解到了幕后发生的事情。我交谈过的工作人员对患者所经历的一切感到震惊。她们也苦于寻找答案：这件事究竟是如何发生的？哪里出了错？患者不知道自己为什么会感到疼痛，医生们也不知道。
And in the absence of information about the true cause of the pain, people came up with stories to explain it. The patients constructed stories about why they felt pain. Staffers at the clinic came up with theories, too. Eventually, the nurse would tell her own story, which would launch a whole new set of stories, the ones her friends and family would come up with, the one that would get argued in court, the one Yale would tell. And all of these stories revealed something about women's pain-- how it's tolerated, interpreted, accounted for, or minimized.
由于缺乏关于疼痛真实原因的信息，人们想出了各种故事来解释它。患者们编造故事来解释为何疼痛；诊所的工作人员也提出了各种理论。最终，那位护士会讲出她自己的故事，这引发了一系列全新的故事：她的朋友和家人编造的故事、法庭上争辩的故事、耶鲁讲述的故事。所有这些故事都揭示了关于女性疼痛的某种本质——它如何被容忍、被解读、被解释或被轻视。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
In fertility treatment, you evaluate the outcomes by whether you wind up with a baby. That's the metric by which success is measured. It all went well if you leave with a live birth. The outcomes here are a lot more complicated for everyone. From Serial Productions and the New York Times, I'm Susan Burton, and this is "The Retrievals." This is Episode 1, "The Patients."
在生育治疗中，你通过是否最终生下孩子来评估结果。这是衡量成功与否的指标。如果你最终活产，那一切都好。但这里的结局对每个人来说都复杂得多。我是苏珊·伯顿，来自 Serial Productions 和《纽约时报》，这是《取卵》，这是第一集《患者》。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
When the retrieval is over, the women are wheeled out to the recovery room. And one of the first things that happens is that they try to come up with an explanation for their pain.
取卵结束时，女性们被推入恢复室。她们做的第一件事，就是试图为自己的疼痛寻找解释。
They put you into the recovery room, and that's where you meet with whoever you were with. And I just remember, that's when I had my phone back, and I was texting my sister-in-law because she was my confidant for all of this, having been through that. And she was just replying, like, oh, my god, how could you-- what do you mean, you felt everything? And I was just like explaining to her. I'm like, I don't know what's wrong. And one of the texts I said, I said, I think I'm immune to fentanyl because I was like, I don't think it works on me.
“把你送到恢复室，在那里你会见到你的陪同人员。我只记得那时我拿回了手机，正给我的嫂子发短信，因为她是我所有这些事情的知己。她回复说，天哪，你怎么会……你什么意思，你说你感觉到了所有的一切？我向她解释说，我不知道怎么了。短信里有一条我说，我觉得我对芬太尼免疫，因为我觉得它对我不起作用。”
I'm not sensitive to fentanyl was a common theory.
“我对芬太尼不敏感”是一个常见的理论。
And I remember when the procedure was done, my family sort of-- we have a family text that's ongoing. And I just remember texting them that it's hard to believe that we have a fentanyl epidemic where people are addicted because it did nothing for me.
“我记得手术结束后，我的家人——我们有个家庭群聊。我记得给他们发了短信，说真不敢相信现在还有芬太尼流行病，因为这东西对我一点用都没有。”
Not all of the women were alert during their procedures. Some were more deeply sedated. They were so out of it during the retrieval that they don't really remember it, or only kind of. The pain hits when they come to.
并非所有女性在手术期间都保持清醒。有些人镇静程度更深。她们在取卵期间意识模糊，几乎不记得发生过什么，或者只有零星记忆。疼痛是在她们清醒时袭来的。
It was bad instantly, and it shouldn't really be bad instantly. You shouldn't wake up and be in horrific, like nightmarish pain. But I woke up, and I was. I mean, it felt like someone had been inside me and gutted me. Yeah, it was like a gutted feeling. It was like someone had been inside me, scraped me hollow. It was burning.
“立刻就开始痛了，而且不应该立刻就痛。你不应该在醒来时就陷入可怕的、噩梦般的痛苦中。但我醒来时，就是这样。我的意思是，感觉就像有人在我体内掏空了一样。是的，那是一种被掏空的感觉。就像有人在我身体里刮过，把我掏空了。那是烧灼感。”
In a way, it is more confusing for the wake-up-later patients. They're not matching each stab of pain to the needle on the screen. It hurts a lot, but it's less explicable, and because of that, scarier.
在某种程度上，对于那些较晚醒来的患者来说，这更让人困惑。她们无法将每一次刺痛与屏幕上的针头对应起来。这很痛，但更无法解释，因此也更可怕。
Your mind just goes to the worst possible places. I'm thinking, am I bleeding, you know? Am I bleeding internally? Normally, pain is a sign-- is protective, right? It tells you something's wrong.
“你的大脑只会往最糟糕的地方想。我在想，我在流血吗？我在体内大出血吗？通常疼痛是一种信号——是一种保护机制，对吧？它告诉你出问题了。”
There's a lot of uncertainty in the recovery room-- an elevated blood pressure, a nurse running around to get ginger ale, a doctor coming by to say, there are fewer eggs than we expected. Are you sure you only want us to fertilize half of them? It's all just very overwhelming. And on top of it, some of the women feel like they're being rushed out of the clinic. Julia is one of them.
恢复室里充满了不确定性——血压升高、护士跑去拿姜汁汽水、医生过来说，“卵子比预期的少，你确定只要把其中一半受精吗？”一切都非常让人崩溃。除此之外，一些女性觉得她们被匆忙赶出了诊所。朱莉就是其中之一。
I remember vomiting. They were giving me some fluids. I was very uncomfortable. There was no way I could walk. They put me in a wheelchair and wheeled me out. And I just had this feeling, like, this is not right.
“我记得我呕吐了。他们给我输液。我非常难受。我根本走不动路。他们把我推上轮椅，把我推了出去。我当时就有一种感觉，这不对劲。”
Julia is 31 years old and already a college professor. This morning, when her husband drove to the clinic, she'd been frantic. There was work on a bridge near their house, and they got stuck. There's only a short window to retrieve the eggs before you ovulate them, and Julia was worried she would miss it. When she arrived at the clinic, she felt a huge relief, like we made it, both we made it on time and we made it to this day. Now, she's feeling something she never expected. At home, she goes upstairs and gets into bed.
朱莉31岁，已经是大学教授了。那天早上，当她丈夫开车去诊所时，她很焦躁。他们家附近的一座桥在施工，堵车了。排卵前取卵的时间窗口很短，朱莉担心错过。当她抵达诊所时，她感到如释重负，感觉我们终于赶上了，既赶上了时间，也赶上了这一天。现在，她感受到了她从未预料到的东西。回到家，她上楼躺在床上。
I fell asleep for a little while, and then I woke up and I was nervous. We had a babysitter here watching my daughter. And I just-- you wake up, you're like, oh, my god, who's with my kid? I need to-- and I walked a few steps to try and go down the stairs, and I realized I really had gone too far from the bed.
“我睡了一会儿，然后醒来，很紧张。我们家有个保姆在照顾我的女儿。醒来时你会想，天哪，谁在陪我的孩子？我需要……我走下楼梯，意识到我真的走得离床太远了。”
By this point, the pain was excruciating, I would say. And I turned to go back to lay down in my bed again. And I mean, I don't remember this, but I blacked out or passed out. And I woke up on the floor, and I kind of busted my lip open.
“到那时候，疼痛已经可以说是剧烈了。我转过身想回到床上躺下。我记不清了，但我昏厥或失去知觉了。我醒来时躺在地上，把嘴唇摔破了。”
Julia calls the clinic, and they tell her that she should go to the ER. She's in so much pain that she can't bend enough to get into a car. An ambulance is called, and when Julia gets to the hospital, they check her out. The retrieval is a safe procedure, but things can go wrong. Your ovary can strangulate. A major artery can get punctured. But none of the obvious things are wrong, and nobody can explain what is. Back home over the weekend, Julia calls the on-call doctor at the clinic multiple times.
朱莉给诊所打电话，他们让她去急诊室。她痛到甚至无法弯腰坐进车里。救护车来了，当朱莉到达医院时，他们检查了她。取卵本应是一项安全的手术，但事情可能会出错。卵巢可能会扭转，动脉可能会被刺穿。但没有发现明显的病因，没人能解释发生了什么。周末在家时，朱莉多次致电诊所的值班医生。
By Sunday, I sort of got the sense I was annoying him.
“到了周日，我感觉自己好像在烦他。”
Julia keeps waiting for a call from her official doctor. By Tuesday, she still hasn't heard from him.
朱莉一直在等她主治医生的电话。到了周二，依然没音讯。
It was impossible for me to understand how he hadn't called me by this point. But I called his office on Tuesday, basically saying, I need to talk to you.
“我无法理解为什么到那时候他还没给我打过电话。于是周二我给他的办公室打电话，基本上是说，我必须和你谈谈。”
I wrote down what he said, and I've kept this note since that time. He said he was not alarmed, but perplexed and surprised at my experience. Those words, I guess, ring pretty hollow now, right, knowing that there was a pattern of many women who had extreme, inexplicable pain after the egg retrieval.
“我写下了他当时说的话，这张字条我一直保存着。他说他不感到恐慌，只是对我的经历感到‘困惑和惊讶’。现在看来，这些话显得非常空洞，对吧？毕竟当时已经有许多女性在取卵后经历了极端且无法解释的疼痛。”
What did you make of that language in the moment, "perplexed and surprised"?
“你当时对‘困惑和惊讶’这种说法怎么看？”
It was-- I mean, I guess, I felt crazy. I mean, by this point, I'm asking myself, am I being difficult? I mean, you just question your sense of self, your ability to assess your situation rationally, which is very disconcerting when that happens, because at least at the end of the day, you have that, right?
“那……我想，我感到自己像个疯子。到那个时候，我在问自己，我是不是很难缠？你会质疑自己的自我认知，质疑自己理性评估情况的能力，这非常令人不安，因为毕竟，你只有这一点理智了，对吧？”
You start thinking about your whole life, right? Like, I'm a pretty high energy person. I take care of a toddler. I have a PhD. I have a job. I run marathons in my free time. You have all these parts of your life that give you this sense of who you are. And then I just felt like they were treating me like I was nuts for still being in pain and just having what I would call a difficult time.
“你开始思考你整个人生，对吧？比如，我是一个精力充沛的人，我照顾蹒跚学步的孩子，我有博士学位，我有工作，我空闲时跑马拉松。你拥有所有这些构成你自我感知的因素。然后我感觉他们把我当成个疯子，因为我还在忍受疼痛，经历着我称之为困难的时刻。”
I just left the office, I mean, crying. I just felt like nobody, nobody cares. That's the way I would describe how I felt in the days after. Like, nobody gives a crap that this was so hard for me.
“我离开诊所时哭了。我感觉没有人，真的没有人关心。这就是我形容在那之后几天感受的方式。没人会在意这对我来说有多艰难。”
In the days after the retrieval, other patients live out versions of the same story. They also call the clinic. They ask, is this normal? They say, the Tylenol isn't helping. At home, they're laid up on the couch. They can't pick up their toddler. They wonder if they really should have scheduled themselves for a shift the next day.
在取卵后的几天里，其他患者经历了同样故事的不同版本。她们也给诊所打电话。她们问，这是正常的吗？她们说，泰诺一点用都没有。在家时，她们躺在沙发上，无法抱起蹒跚学步的孩子。她们怀疑自己是否真的应该安排第二天去上班。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
Not all staffers at the clinic are dismissive, but even when they respond with concern, there aren't any real answers. Some of these conversations take place days after the procedure, like at follow-ups to talk about next steps.
诊所里并非所有员工都是冷漠的，但即使她们表示关心，也没有实质性的答案。其中一些对话发生在术后几天，比如为了讨论后续步骤的随访时。
You didn't really talk to the office until day five or day six, which is when I found out that none of the eggs had survived. None were healthy enough to go to testing. And we had to talk about moving forward. And that's when I really expressed my sort of shock that the procedure was as painful as it was and talked about if there were other pain management protocols that could be considered at that point.
“直到第五天或第六天我才真正和办公室交谈，那时我才知道没有一个卵子存活下来。没有一个健康到可以进行检测。我们不得不讨论下一步该怎么走。那时我才真正表达了对手术疼痛程度的震惊，并询问是否可以在那一刻考虑其他疼痛管理方案。”
And I was told that that was the best pain medication that was available. And my doctor prescribed me an anxiety medication to take before the next procedure. And I remember saying to my husband, I think it's strange because I'm not anxious about a medical procedure. It was the pain. It was severe pain, not anxiety about going into it.
“结果我被告知那是现有的最好的止痛药。我的医生给我开了抗焦虑药物，让我在下一次手术前服用。我记得我对丈夫说，我觉得这很奇怪，因为我并不对医疗手术感到焦虑，我担心的是疼痛。是剧烈的疼痛，而不是对医疗程序的焦虑。”
The next time that I saw my doctor, he asked me how the procedure went, and I said, it was really, really painful. And he was kind of like a little bit concerned, but then he just didn't say anything after that, so I was like, OK, I guess. And this was my first time doing it, so I didn't know any better. So I was like, oh, OK, I guess it's supposed to be painful.
“下一次见到医生时，他问我手术感觉如何，我说，那真的很痛、很痛。他表现出了一点关切，但随后什么都没再说。所以我当时想，好吧，就这样吧。这是我第一次做，所以我不知道是不是本来就该这么痛，所以我说，哦，好吧，我想可能本来就是这样。”
Other women are talking about what happened with family and friends.
其他女性则在与家人和朋友谈论发生的这一切。
So at that point, I had talked to a couple of family members who had done retrievals, and I felt even worse. There's nothing like feeling shame from another female and unintentional, too. Like, that just seems weird because I was wheeled back there and joked with the staff and then fell asleep and woke up and was fine.
“到那时候，我已经和几位经历过取卵的家人谈过了，我感觉更糟了。没有什么比感受到来自另一位女性的羞耻感更难受了，而且她们还是无意的。这感觉很奇怪，因为我被推进去，和医护人员开过玩笑，然后睡着了，醒来觉得很好。”
And that seemed to be the general consensus between procedures at different clinics, that, oh, yeah, I was kind of alert, but I didn't feel anything. It was really no big deal. Like, the shots ahead of time were way worse than the actual procedure. And I started shutting down after hearing those stories that this was on me. Something wasn't right with my tolerance and my ability to handle this.
“在不同诊所进行手术的共识似乎是，‘哦，是的，我有点清醒，但什么都没感觉到。真的没什么大不了的。术前的针剂比手术本身难受多了。’听到这些故事后，我开始封闭自己，觉得这都是我的问题。我的耐受力和处理能力有问题。”
The women are already settling on their stories about what happened to them. I'm immune to fentanyl. It's my fault. It's supposed to be painful. The clinic tells patients that they may experience mild discomfort, but now some of them have recalibrated their expectations, including Lynn, who will have eight retrievals at the clinic. All of them will cause her excruciating pain.
女性们已经开始接受关于发生在她们身上的事情的解释。我芬太尼免疫。这是我的错。这本来就该很痛。诊所告诉患者她们可能会经历轻微的不适，但现在一些人已经调整了心理预期，包括琳，她在该诊所进行了八次取卵。每一次都让她经历了剧痛。
Again, you hear about IVF and how tough of a process it is mentally and physically. And I just thought, this is what I have to do. This is what I have to do. And sort of just thought, this is what women go through.
“再说一次，你听说过试管婴儿的心理和身体过程有多艰难。我只是认为，这是我必须做的。这是我必须做的。我想，这就是女性必须经历的过程。”
Yale declined to offer information about how reports of pain were addressed at the clinic or to answer any other questions.
耶鲁大学拒绝提供关于诊所如何处理疼痛报告的信息，也拒绝回答任何其他问题。
Susan Burton. Coming up, how a person can go from thinking that a nurse is stealing the fentanyl, which, of course, was right, to thinking, oh, maybe there's some other explanation. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
我是苏珊·伯顿。接下来，一个人如何从认为“护士在偷芬太尼”（当然，这是对的）到认为“哦，也许有其他解释”。几分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our show, we're bringing you the first episode of our producer Susan Burton's brand new podcast, The Retrievals. Susan picks up the story where she left off.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目中，我们将为您呈现我们的制作人苏珊·伯顿的全新播客——《取卵》的第一集。苏珊继续讲述她的故事。
Of the 12 patients I spoke to, most are white. The one Black woman in the group was often the only Black woman in the clinic waiting room. Everyone in the group identified as a woman. While a couple of them were pursuing pregnancy for the first time as they neared 40, most did not fit that stereotype.
在我采访的12名患者中，大多数是白人。群体中唯一的一名黑人女性通常是诊所候诊室里唯一的黑人。群体中的每个人都自我认同为女性。虽然其中几人是在接近40岁时第一次尝试怀孕，但大多数并不符合那种刻板印象。
Most were married to men, one to a woman. That patient would provide the eggs, and her wife would carry the pregnancy. Her wife presents as more stereotypically masculine, doesn't wear women's clothing. And at first, family members were like, are you sure you want to do it this way? Yes, they were sure.
大多数人嫁给了男性，有一个嫁给了女性。那位患者提供卵子，她的妻子怀孕。她的妻子表现得更倾向于传统男性化，不穿女性服装。起初，家庭成员们问：你们确定要这样做吗？是的，她们确定。
One was doing this on her own at 41 after the end of a long relationship. Another left her boyfriend partway through the process and then fell in love with the new guy at the office. One was born in Iran and came to the US as a refugee. Another grew up in Jamaica.
有一位在长期关系结束后，41岁时独自进行这项治疗。另一位在过程中与男友分手，然后在办公室爱上了新男友。一位出生在伊朗，作为难民来到美国。另一位在牙买加长大。
One had what she described as a horrible childhood. She essentially had to raise herself. Another longed to have a second baby because she was so close to all of her siblings. One had type 1 diabetes and was used to everyone always attributing all medical issues to, oh, it's your diabetes.
一位经历了她所描述的“可怕的童年”。她基本上是独自长大的。另一位渴望生第二个孩子，因为她和所有兄弟姐妹关系亲密。还有一位患有1型糖尿病，习惯了所有人总是把所有医疗问题归咎于“哦，是你的糖尿病”。
All of them worked. A special ed teacher, an accountant at a maritime firm, and a lecturer at Yale in the Department of American Studies. Her name is Leah.
她们都在工作。一名特殊教育老师，一家海事公司的会计，还有耶鲁大学美国研究系的讲师。她的名字叫莉亚。
Her scholarship encompasses a variety of subjects-- exile and migration-- she's the patient who came to the US as a refugee from Iran-- and gender. From the beginning of her treatment, Leah located her experience within a context of assumptions about women patients, that they're unreliable narrators of their own symptoms, that they are anxious, exaggerating.
她的研究涵盖了多种学科——流亡和移民（她是作为伊朗难民来到美国的患者）以及性别问题。从治疗一开始，莉亚就将自己的经历置于对女性患者的固有假设背景中：她们对自己症状的陈述不可靠，她们感到焦虑，她们在夸大其词。
But I remember the first time I went in there to get ready for the ultrasound, there was blood on the floor from a previous person's ultrasound. And I have to tell you, it was as ominous as signs fucking come. And I just remember Navid was with me, I think. Was Navid with me? Oh, no, he couldn't go inside. He was waiting in the car. My husband was waiting in the car.
“但我记得第一次进去准备做超声波时，地板上有前一个人的超声波检查留下的血迹。我得告诉你，那是最不祥的兆头。我记得纳维德和我在一起，我想。是纳维德和我在一起吗？哦，不，他不能进去。他在车里等我。我丈夫在车里等我。”
I was just shaking. I was like, this isn't good. I mean, it was like, you walk in, and I was like, there's blood? You guys left blood over? What is going on here?
“我当时浑身发抖。我说，这不对劲。我的意思是，你走进去，然后我说，这有血？你们留下了血？这到底是怎么回事？”
Did you say anything? Did you say that?
“你有说出来吗？你说了吗？”
But here's the thing, and this is where it begins, is, you are treated like a hysterical woman from the second you walk in there. So you already know. And as a person who-- I study this stuff. I teach this stuff. And you're there, and you're like, oh, this is actually what's happening right now.
“但重点是——这就是事情开始的地方——你从走进那个地方的那一秒起，就被当成了一个歇斯底里的女人来对待。所以你已经知道了。作为一个研究这些东西、教授这些东西的人，你在那里，你会想，哦，这就是现在正在发生的事情。”
Here comes like Freud's patient, the hysterical woman who's childless, and angry, and hormonal, and terrified, and bitchy, and mean. And that's how we're going to treat her.
“弗洛伊德笔下的患者来了，那个没孩子、愤怒、荷尔蒙紊乱、恐惧、刻薄又卑鄙的歇斯底里的女人。这就是他们对待她的方式。”
Hysteria comes from the Greek word for "uterus." Ancient explanations for it involve an empty uterus. A woman was hysterical because her uterus was not full. Unanchored, the uterus roved through the body, which was what made women sick and crazy. To fix hysteria, you really needed to fill that uterus up.
“歇斯底里”（Hysteria）源自希腊语中的“子宫”（uterus）。古代对它的解释涉及到空子宫。女性歇斯底里是因为她的子宫不充盈。如果没有固定，子宫会在体内游走，这使女性生病并变得疯狂。为了治愈歇斯底里，你确实需要填满那个子宫。
So with the blood, I remember being like, there's blood on the floor. You know? I was really upset. And they're like, OK, OK. I mean, it turned right back on me. And I remember one of the nurses was like, OK, well, you can calm down. I was told to calm down.
“所以看到血的时候，我记得我说：‘地板上有血。’你知道吗？我真的很心烦。他们说：‘好，好。’我的意思是，责任又回到了我身上。我记得其中一位护士说：‘好了，你可以冷静点。’我被告知要冷静下来。”
And then when they're doing the ultrasounds, of course, someone's doing a transvaginal ultrasound. So there's literally like this stick that's inside of you, and they're moving it around. And if you cringe, oh, OK, it'll just be like another-- it's just another second. It's just, OK, just be patient. So you're constantly over emphasizing or over dramatizing what's happening. It's not that big of a deal.
“然后当他们做超声波时，当然，有人在做阴道超声。所以确实有一根棍子在你的体内，他们在移动它。如果你畏缩，‘哦，好吧，再等一秒……再多一秒……这只是小事。好，耐心点。’所以你总是被暗示在夸大其词。没那么大不了。”
Leah felt like her doctor wasn't listening to her. She also didn't trust her assigned nurse. Then came Leah's first retrieval. She felt her pain wasn't taken seriously by anyone. She says they all blew her off. Leah wasn't happy with her treatment, but she decided to continue.
莉亚觉得她的医生没在听她说话。她也不信任分配给她的护士。然后是莉亚的第一次取卵。她觉得她的痛苦没被任何人重视。她说她们全都在敷衍她。莉亚对治疗不满意，但她决定继续。
Here I was. I saw it. I felt it. I was alarmed by it. But I kept going because I wanted to have a baby.
“我就在那里。我看到了。我感觉到了。我对此感到警觉。但我还是继续了，因为我想生个孩子。”
Leah asked for a new doctor. He oversaw her next cycle, and soon she went in for another retrieval.
莉亚要求换一位医生。他接手了她的下一次周期，很快她就去进行另一次取卵。
Right after you're in that room, the anesthesiologist came up to me, and she said, you know what? You were waking up. You were waking up. We ought to give you some more meds. You were waking up.
“就在你进那个房间后，麻醉师走到我面前说：‘你知道吗？你刚才在醒过来。你在醒过来。我们得给你多用点药。你刚才醒了。’”
So again, you, your body, you were nervous. You were agitated. You burdened us. Your kind of uncontrollable body put us in a position where we actually had to give you more drugs. You were waking up, so we had to give you more fentanyl. And I was like, oh.
“所以再次，你，你的身体，你紧张了。你激动了。你给我们添了麻烦。你那种无法控制的身体让我们不得不给你多用药。你刚才醒了，所以我们不得不给你更多的芬太尼。我当时想，哦。”
But again, to them, to them, I'm this woman who's already on edge. I already left the doctor because I didn't like the doctor. So the other physicians and the other nurses all know this about me. I'm a kind of already unruly, perhaps entitled, overly kind of needy woman who's just really angry that she doesn't have a baby.
“但再次强调，对她们来说，我已经是一个处于崩溃边缘的女人。我已经换过医生了，因为我不喜欢前一个。所以其他医生和护士都知道我的这点。我是一个已经有些不服管教、也许有权利感、过于需要关注的女人，只是因为没孩子而非常愤怒。”
There's a balance you have to strike as a woman patient. You have to complain just the right amount to be taken seriously, but not so much that you seem shrill. Still, your pain is more likely to be underestimated than men's. Black women are more likely to have their pain ignored, no matter what they do. All of this, we know from the literature and also from life. In my life, I've been the kind of patient where if I've ever spoken up, I felt like I need to be obsequious later to protect myself. That is what I felt I needed to perform.
作为一名女性患者，你必须找到一种平衡。你必须投诉得恰到好处才能被认真对待，但又不能多到让你看起来尖锐。尽管如此，你的痛苦被低估的可能性依然比男性高。黑人女性无论做什么，她们的痛苦都更有可能被忽视。这一切，我们从文献中知道，也从生活中知道。在我生命中，我曾是那种患者，如果我说了什么，我会觉得自己事后需要表现得恭顺才能保护自己。那就是我感到自己需要表现出来的样子。
Leah knew she'd need to perform a whole range of things in order to get help-- stern, docile, smart, stupid, agreeable. And now, on a gurney in the recovery room, Leah became an observer. She would remember what was happening. She would write about this one day. She tuned into the language and to the emphasis that, to her, seemed so interesting and fucked up and to the syntax that seemed to place the blame on her body.
莉亚知道，为了得到帮助，她需要表现出各种样子——严肃、顺从、聪明、笨拙、随和。现在，躺在恢复室的担架上，莉亚变成了一名观察者。她会记住正在发生的事情。她总有一天会写下这些。她调动起感官，去关注那些对她来说显得如此有趣又荒谬的用语和强调，去关注那些似乎将过错归咎于她身体的语法。
But at the same time, Leah had also internalized the narrative that her body was to blame. Her body was inadequate, deficient. That was why she was here. Her body had had miscarriages. Her body didn't make enough eggs. Her body couldn't cooperate long enough to get through a critical procedure.
但与此同时，莉亚也内化了“她的身体应该被指责”的叙事。她的身体是不够好的、有缺陷的。这就是她在这里的原因。她的身体流过产。她的身体产不出足够的卵子。她的身体无法坚持足够长的时间来完成一个关键的手术。
Oh, god, my body. Like, here it goes again. Not only can I not have a baby, I also can't even just lay still with the right amount of fentanyl.
“哦，天哪，我的身体。你看，又来了。不仅我生不出孩子，我还连躺着忍受标准剂量芬太尼都做不到。”
Leah wasn't the only woman who had an area of expertise that was directly applicable here in a way that is kind of uncanny. For example, there are multiple patients who work in health care, including one who's designed systems for the safe storage of medications. There's a nurse anesthetist. She thought the anesthesia was the one part of fertility treatment she wouldn't have to worry about. And of course, there's the addiction researcher, Katie, who had the prophetic fantasy.
莉亚并不是唯一一个拥有相关专业知识的人，这种情况简直不可思议。例如，有几位患者从事医疗保健工作，其中一位曾设计过药物安全存储系统。还有一位麻醉护士。她认为麻醉是生育治疗中她唯一不用担心的一环。当然，还有那位有着预言性幻想的成瘾研究员凯蒂。
What's unique about you is that not only did you know something was wrong, you knew exactly what was wrong.
“你的独特之处在于，你不仅知道出问题了，你还准确地知道出了什么问题。”
I did.
“确实。”
Yet still, you constructed this other narrative to explain it.
“但你仍然构建了另一个叙事来解释它。”
Yes.
“是的。”
Like other patients, Katie had expertise that gave her knowledge, but she and others pushed that knowledge aside. They decided not to know what they knew in order to keep going. I wanted Katie to lay out the path to that cognitive dissonance. I wanted her to explain exactly how she got from one story to the other.
像其他患者一样，凯蒂拥有给予她知识的专业背景，但她和其他人一样把这些知识抛在了一边。她们选择不去知道自己所知的事，以便能继续前进。我想让凯蒂梳理出通往那种认知失调的路径。我想让她解释清楚她是怎样从一个故事跳到另一个故事的。
I mean, as I've told you, I came out of that procedure, and I remember immediately texting my friends, who are also colleagues in addiction research at Yale, like, the nurse is stealing the fentanyl. It just seemed so obvious. But then you sort come out of this-- I remember just coming out of the shock and recovering from the procedure, and things just go on. No one is addressing the fact that I was sober during the procedure.
“正如我告诉你的，我走出手术室时，我记得立刻给我的朋友发了短信，她们也是耶鲁成瘾研究的同事，说‘那个护士在偷芬太尼’。这看起来太明显了。但后来你走出这种……我记得只是从震惊中走出来，从手术中恢复，事情照常进行。没有人处理我在手术期间清醒的事实。”
And I remember violently shaking in recovery from the shock. I don't know that that's related to having the procedure with or without fentanyl, but that's how my body responded. And my nurse was there. And I remember her saying something like, I think it was so painful because we got so many eggs. And so it was just sort of this positive, kind of false narrative about what had happened.
“我记得在恢复时因为休克而剧烈颤抖。我不知道那是否与手术中是否用了芬太尼有关，但我的身体就是那样反应的。我的护士在那里。我记得她说，‘我想是因为我们取出的卵子太多了，所以才这么痛。’于是这成了关于刚才发生之事的某种积极的、带有某种虚假叙事性质的说法。”
And so then I think I coped by coming up with an alternate explanation, which was that I do remember waking up during having my wisdom teeth being pulled when I was a kid to the nurse saying, shit, shit, and then giving me more drugs, putting me back under. So the other explanation for me was that maybe I'm not sensitive to certain opiates.
“所以我认为我通过想出一个替代解释来应对，那就是我记得小时候拔智齿时曾醒过来，护士说‘糟糕，糟糕’，然后给我加了药，又让我睡着了。所以对我来说另一个解释是，也许我对某些阿片类药物不敏感。”
And I remember also that kind of became my narrative with-- my friends and colleagues kind of remember me sort of switching to that narrative and saying, like, well, maybe you're not sensitive to fentanyl. So I started to kind of just tell myself a story about my pain, just try to understand. It's a way of just understanding my experience and thinking, yeah, maybe this is what happened.
“我也记得那成了我与……我的朋友和同事们之间的叙事，她们似乎记得我换了那种说法，说，‘好吧，也许你对芬太尼不敏感。’所以我开始尝试告诉自己一个关于我痛苦的故事，试着理解它。这只是一种理解我的经历的方式，并想，是的，也许这就是发生的事情。”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
The story becomes a way not only to explain pain, but to cope with it, a way to not only make sense of the pain, but to manage it, to tamp it down, get through it. In this way, the story becomes the medicine that the patients weren't given.
这个故事不仅成了解释痛苦的方式，也成了应对它的方式，不仅是赋予痛苦某种意义，也是为了管理它，压制它，熬过去。通过这种方式，故事成了患者们没能得到的药物。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
The women gear up for second, third retrievals. They changed their diets. They cut chemicals out of their home. They read the books the nurses recommend, or they get ready for embryo transfers. They make reservations at a hotel in town so that they won't have to drive home over a bumpy road. Despite these efforts, some of the women miscarry.
女性们为第二次、第三次取卵做准备。她们改变饮食。她们清除了家里的化学品。她们阅读护士推荐的书籍，或者为胚胎移植做准备。她们在城里的酒店预订房间，这样就不必在颠簸的路上开车回家。尽管做出了这些努力，一些女性还是流产了。
One woman wakes up about 10 days after her embryo transfer with some spotting. Don't think anything of that yet, a nurse reassures her. But the pregnancy test comes back negative. When do you think you might want to get started again? Her doctor asks her at a virtual follow-up appointment. I'm not ready, the patient says.
一位女性在胚胎移植后约10天醒来，发现有一些斑点。护士安慰她说：“还别多想。”但妊娠测试结果是阴性。在虚拟随访预约中，医生问她：“你打算什么时候再开始？”“我还没准备好，”患者说。
She closes the telehealth, and that's the last time she talked to the doctor. She never goes back to that clinic. She stops fertility treatment and doesn't know when or if she will ever resume it. She never wants to go through an egg retrieval again.
她关掉远程医疗页面，那是她最后一次和那位医生交谈。她再也没有回到那家诊所。她停止了生育治疗，不知道什么时候（如果有的话）会恢复。她再也不想经历一次取卵手术了。
Fertility treatment doesn't always result in a baby. It's not just giving yourself shots that's hard. It's the cycle of hope and loss. It just clobbers you. And the longer you stay in it, the more the drugs mess with your head. It's called the Clomid crazies for a reason, one of the women tells me.
生育治疗并不总是能带来孩子。不仅仅是注射药物很辛苦。那是希望与失去的循环。它简直要把你击垮。你深陷其中的时间越长，药物对你大脑的干扰就越大。其中一位女性告诉我，这被称为“克罗米芬疯狂”是有原因的。
And the money, always the money. If your insurance covers this, it probably only covers a few cycles. There's so much pressure on each one. Once you have to pay out of pocket, you're talking maybe 15k for one cycle, and that's the low end. Some of the women are keeping their treatments secret. One of them can't even tell her own mother. It's hard. It's hard to begin with, even without this extra layer that's been added on to this now, the pain and the fear of more of it.
还有钱，永远是钱的问题。如果你的保险涵盖此项，可能也只涵盖几次周期。每一次都有巨大的压力。一旦你需要自费，一个周期可能需要1.5万美元，这还是起步价。一些女性对治疗保密。其中一个甚至不能告诉自己的母亲。这很艰难。即便没有现在额外添加的痛苦和恐惧，它本身就已经够难了。
The first time, I went in clueless, thinking, you're not going to feel a thing. So I think the second time, I had a lot more anxiety.
“第一次去的时候，我一无所知，心想，你什么都不会感觉到。所以我觉得第二次时，我有更多的焦虑。”
Laura doesn't get as many eggs as she hoped for the first time around. It's urgent that she start cancer treatment, and the doctors accelerate her cycle. Her second retrieval is scheduled for barely more than two weeks after her first. That morning, Laura's mother drives her to the clinic and sits in the waiting room, while Laura goes back for the procedure.
劳拉第一次取出的卵子比她希望的少。她必须尽快开始癌症治疗，医生加快了她的周期。她的第二次取卵安排在第一次后仅两周多一点。那天早上，劳拉的母亲开车送她去诊所，坐在候诊室里，而劳拉进去做手术。
And I was shocked. I was shocked again that it was the same situation. I'm thrusting my hips and telling these-- wide awake, speaking to them. And I was just like, I feel everything you're doing. And that was when I remember actually saying to them, I could drive myself home right now. I'm that alert.
“我又震惊了。我又震惊于情况竟然一样。我在顶胯，告诉这些……我完全清醒，和她们说话。我当时想，我能感觉到你们在做的一切。就在那时，我记得我确实对她们说，‘我现在就可以开车回家了。我非常清醒。’”
In the recovery room, Laura gets her phone back and just like last time, texts her sister-in-law. She sees her mom. She tells them both how much pain she's in.
在恢复室，劳拉拿回手机，和上次一样，给嫂子发短信。她看到了妈妈。她告诉她们两个自己有多痛苦。
So my sister-in-law right away was like, oh, my god, I cannot believe you felt that again. But my mom, she just felt-- it's hard because she had seen me go through so much as it was with the cancer, any mother who has to live watching their daughter go through that.
“我嫂子立刻说，‘天哪，我简直不敢相信你又感受到了。’但我妈，她只是觉得……这很难，因为她已经亲眼目睹了我的癌症治疗，任何看着自己女儿经历这些的母亲，都会心碎。”
And then for me to tell her, this was supposed to be a special moment because we're preserving my fertility. And-- I'm sorry. [CRYING] And for her to see that, it hurts her to see me in pain, you know. And I was just like, well, thank god. I think this was the last time I had to do that. So.
“然后我告诉她，这本该是一个特殊的时刻，因为我们在冷冻我的生育力。而且……我很抱歉。[哭泣] 她看着这一切，看着我忍受痛苦对她来说是一种伤害，你知道吗。我当时想，好吧，谢天谢地，我想这是我最后一次做这个了。所以。”
What did the two of you do the rest of that day? Did she drive you home?
“那一天的剩余时间你们两个是怎么过的？她开车送你回家的吗？”
Yeah, she drove me home, and she stayed with me because she had already been staying with me a lot during the day after my surgeries because at that point, I still wasn't allowed to lift more than 5 pounds because I was still recovering from the other surgeries.
“是的，她送我回家了，她留下来陪我，因为在手术后的日子里她一直都在照顾我，因为那时候我还不被允许提超过5磅的东西，因为我还在从其他手术中恢复。”
So, yeah, she was with me and made me lunch and comforted me. And just, we were like, OK, so now we just go back to waiting and hoping we get a good number. And I just moved on from it because I faced many more surgeries that year as well. So I kind of had to just switch back into that survival mode. Like, OK, well, now we just battle the next thing, so.
“所以，是的，她陪着我，给我做了午餐，安慰我。我们只是觉得，好吧，现在我们又回到了等待，祈祷我们能得到一个好的数字。我就那样从那里走出来了，因为我那年还面临着更多手术。所以我不得不切换回那种生存模式。就像，好吧，现在我们只要去战胜下一件事。”
Ugh. In the other surgeries you had, like cancer related surgeries, what were your experiences of pain?
“呃。在你经历的其他癌症相关手术中，你对疼痛的感受是怎样的？”
It's actually interesting that you bring that up because when I did have my double mastectomy, I was hospitalized. I think I was in for a day or two days. And strangely enough, the night nurse forgot to give me morphine. So I actually was awake and in pain the entire night. And I have a gluten allergy, so they couldn't feed me anything because the kitchen was closed. So I spent the entire night vomiting because they were trying to give me like Percocets or something.
“有趣的是你提到了这一点，因为当我做双侧乳房切除术时，我住院了。我想我住了两天。奇怪的是，晚班护士忘了给我吗啡。所以我整晚都是清醒且痛苦的。我有麸质过敏，因为厨房关门了，他们没法给我提供任何食物。所以我整晚都在呕吐，因为他们试图给我塞必考或者别的药。”
Ugh.
“呃。”
And so I know what pain feels like. Whatever. And the next morning, the doctor goes, I don't understand why she didn't give it to you. It was on the order. And I had a really young nurse. Whatever. This is completely unrelated to that, but I know what pain feels like. I've been through it.
“所以我知道疼痛是什么感觉。随它去吧。第二天早上，医生说，‘我不明白她为什么没给你。医嘱上写着。’那是个很年轻的护士。随便吧。这与那件事完全无关，但我知道疼痛是什么感觉。我经历过。”
And then when I was hospitalized at Christmas, that's funny that you bring that up because my sister-in-law actually had pointed out. She goes, do you remember when you kept telling me you were immune to fentanyl? She goes, when I did a search on my phone-- she's really savvy. You can type in fentanyl in text messages, and it'll bring up every conversation.
“然后在圣诞节住院时，你提到这点很有意思，因为我嫂子确实指出了。她说，‘你还记得你一直告诉我你对芬太尼免疫吗？’她说，‘当我在手机上搜索时……’她真的很精明。你可以在短信中输入‘芬太尼’，它会调出所有的对话。”
She goes, I actually found one from when you were hospitalized at Christmas saying that you were on fentanyl. And I guess she had sent me a picture of her Christmas tree, and I had made a comment like, oh, my god, did your house burn down? And she was just like-- and she was like, what are you talking about? And I said, I don't know. The nurse just gave me fentanyl. And so she goes, look, Laura, so it does work on you.
“她说，‘我确实找到了一条你圣诞节住院时发的短信，说你正在用芬太尼。’我想当时她发了一张她圣诞树的照片给我，我评论说，‘天哪，你家房子是不是烧了？’她当时只是……她当时想，你在说什么？我说，我不知道。护士刚给我用了芬太尼。所以她说，‘看，劳拉，所以它对你是有用的。’”
Oh, wow.
“哦，天哪。”
And this was a month prior. And that didn't even dawn on me. Like, oh, my god. But when it came time for the other thing, I was just like, oh, it must not work on me because I just felt like nobody had heard what I was saying, so it just didn't exist. It was in my head. So yeah. So I don't know. Was I foolish because I didn't dispute it more? Maybe not. I don't know. But I believe them. You trust them.
“那是在一个月前。我甚至都没意识到。比如，天哪。但当另一件事发生时，我只是想，哦，它一定对我不起作用，因为我觉得没人听我说话，所以它根本不存在。那是我头脑里的幻觉。所以是的。所以我不知道。我是不是因为没多争辩而显得很蠢？也许吧。我不知道。但我相信她们。你信任她们。”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
Months pass. Some of the women get pregnant. Others are still trying. Some of them are still showing up at that clinic for blood draws when they open their mailboxes in December 2020.
几个月过去了。一些女性怀孕了。其他人还在尝试。她们中的一些人即使在2020年12月打开邮箱时，还在去那家诊所抽血。
Christmas was on a Friday of 2020, and the mail arrived on Thursday. It was Christmas Eve. And I was busy. And I just thought, I'm not going to go get the mail today. And I waited until Monday the 28th. And it was a nice day. I went outside, I got the mail. And I got this letter.
“2020年圣诞节是周五，邮件在周四到达。那是平安夜。我太忙了。我只是想，今天不去拿邮件了。我等到28号周一。那是个好天气。我出门，拿了邮件。我收到了这封信。”
So I got this letter in the mail. It's nothing fancy. It's Yale envelope. I'm assuming it's a bill. The bills never stopped coming with IVF.
“所以我在邮件里收到了这封信。没什么特别的。那是耶鲁的信封。我以为是账单。试管婴儿的账单从没停过。”
You get so much-- when you work at Yale, also, you just get Yale emblazoned mail. And so you're like, oh, OK, whatever. It was like this thin thing, and I was like, oh, they changed locations or something. It's like, this is not important.
“当你在耶鲁工作时，你也会收到很多印着耶鲁标志的邮件。所以你会想，哦，好的，随便吧。那东西很薄，我想，哦，他们搬了地址什么的。我想，这不重要。”
And instead of just setting it aside, I happened to open it. And I was furious.
“而我没有把它放在一边，反而打开了它。我当时气疯了。”
And it says, Dear Kathleen Garrison, I'm writing to you in my role as director of Yale Reproductive Endocrinology and Infertility to let you know that we have learned of an event that may have involved your care.
“信上写着，‘亲爱的凯瑟琳·加里森，我以耶鲁生殖内分泌和不孕不育主任的身份写这封信，是为了告知您，我们获悉了一起可能涉及您护理的事件。’”
That they've become aware that the nurse was switching out the fentanyl with the saline.
她们意识到那位护士一直在用生理盐水替换芬太尼。
As a result, some patients may have received saline instead of the intended narcotic medication during their procedures. While there's no reason to believe that this event has had any negative effect on your health or the outcome of the care that you received, we believe that you should be informed.
“因此，一些患者在手术过程中可能接收到的是生理盐水，而非预期的麻醉药物。虽然没有理由认为该事件对您的健康或您所接受护理的结果产生负面影响，但我们认为您应该知情。”
They make this stupid comment in the letter that there was no harm done from this happening. And I don't know if Holl was home or I called her. And I was like, bullshit. No harm done?
“她们在信里说了这么蠢的话，说这件事没造成任何伤害。我不知道霍尔当时是否在家，或者我给她打了电话。我说，‘胡扯。没造成伤害？’”
Don't send me a letter and tell me that we're confident no one's outcomes were affected by this. I know my outcomes were affected by this. I know what I experienced and went through.
“别发这种信告诉我你们确信没人受影响。我知道我的结果受到了影响。我知道我经历并忍受了什么。”
But Yale wasn't going to help me. They didn't think there was harm. They didn't think it was a problem that it was the most-- honestly, I think it was one of the most disrespectful ways they probably could have notified any of us that it had happened. That, oh, we had this little breach, and you're fine. No biggie. Go about your day.
“但耶鲁没打算帮我。她们不觉得那是伤害。她们不觉得这是个问题，这是最……老实说，我认为这可能是她们能想到的最不尊重人的通知方式。‘哦，我们有一个小违规，但你没事。没什么大不了。继续过你的日子吧。’”
Again, no one reached out to talk with us or to see what we experienced as patients. My only communication about it was through the letter. And that's still to this day.
“再一次，没人联系我们去谈谈或看看我们作为患者经历了什么。我关于此事的唯一沟通就是通过那封信。直到今天依然如此。”
And yet, in addition to fury, there's also vindication. When they learn the news, however they learn it, the women text their twin sister or run inside to their husband or weep in their kitchen.
然而，除了愤怒之外，还有一种“被平反”的感觉。当她们得知这个消息时，无论她们是如何得知的，她们都会发短信给双胞胎姐妹，或者跑进屋去找丈夫，或者在厨房里哭泣。
It was mind blowing. I immediately called my mother. I immediately called my sister-in-law. And I'm like, oh. Like, I don't know. Something had just hit. Like, it all makes sense now.
“这太让人震惊了。我立刻给我妈打了电话。我立刻给我嫂子打了电话。我说，哦。就像，我不知道。有什么东西突然击中了。就像，这一切现在都说得通了。”
And it was like, OK, it all makes sense. It was almost a relief, a relief to know I'm not crazy. There's nothing wrong with my body. I don't have something blocking opioids or where my body is wrong and doesn't react to medicine.
“这就好比，OK，一切都说得通了。那几乎是一种解脱，知道我没疯的解脱。我的身体没问题。我没有什么阻断阿片类药物的东西，也不是我的身体有问题、对药物没反应。”
And but it also shows how much they ignored my pleas for help and saying-- like, nobody believed me. And so, in a sense, it was like relief, just knowing that what I felt was real.
“但这同时也显示了她们有多么忽视我寻求帮助的恳求，并说……没人相信我。所以从某种意义上说，这是一种解脱，因为知道我的感受是真实的。”
But there's more. The letter continues.
但还有更多。信件继续写道：
The law enforcement investigation and our own review have found no reason to believe that you were exposed to an infection due to this event. Even so, we can appreciate that you may want further reassurance. And if you wish, we will arrange for you to be tested for a group of bloodborne infections at no charge.
“执法调查和我们自己的审查发现，没有理由认为您因该事件而接触到了感染。即便如此，我们理解您可能需要进一步的保证。如果您愿意，我们将安排您免费进行一组血源性感染检测。”
And I was like, what the fuck?
“我当时就想，这TM是在说什么？”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
Those words, not alarmed, but perplexed and surprised, came back to me, right? And you just feel like so completely let down by this institution that's supposed to make you feel safe and, I mean, keep you safe, right? An institution that's supposed to keep you safe, right? That was gone.
那些话，“不感到恐慌，只是困惑和惊讶”，又回到了我脑海里，对吧？你会觉得自己被这个本该让你感到安全、本该保护你的机构完全抛弃了。一个本该保护你安全的机构，对吧？那种感觉消失了。
But maybe the most remarkable thing about the letter is the way it addresses pain. It seems to be saying, you did not feel what you felt.
但也许这封信最引人注目的是它处理疼痛的方式。它似乎在说：你并没有感觉到你所感受到的。
I also want to assure you that the fertility center routinely uses a combination of pain medications during procedures. We closely monitor patients for signs of discomfort during every procedure and adjust medications or add medications as needed. In this way, we can be confident that our patients stay comfortable, even if one medication is not working. Well, I don't believe that accurately describes my experience. [LAUGHS] And then it goes on to say if you have any questions or want a blood test, here's who you can call.
“我还想向您保证，生育中心在手术过程中会常规使用止痛药物组合。我们在每次手术中都会密切监测患者是否有不适迹象，并根据需要调整或增加药物。这样，我们可以确信即使一种药物不起作用，我们的患者也会感到舒适。”“好吧，我不认为这准确地描述了我的经历。”[笑] 然后信里继续说，如果你有任何问题或想要验血，这是你可以联系的对象。
The women put the letter on the counter in shock. For months, they'd been constructing their own stories about what happened to them. Now they have Yale's story, which is that this is barely a story at all. The questions the patients have been asking all along have a new focus.
女性们震惊地把信放在柜台上。几个月来，她们一直在编造关于自己身上发生了什么的故事。现在她们有了耶鲁的故事，也就是这几乎算不上是个故事。患者们一直以来提出的问题有了新的焦点。
As soon as I received that letter, it's like, how does this happen? And how does it happen at Yale, a hospital system with such a great reputation? And how did it happen for so long? So many things had to go wrong for this to happen as long as it did.
“当我收到那封信时，我就想，这是怎么发生的？这怎么会发生在耶鲁，一个拥有如此好声誉的医疗系统？它怎么会持续这么久？发生了这么多事才让它持续了这么久。”
How does an entire facility let this happen? Who trained them? Who thought that this was OK? I get sent home with-- I get packages in the mail with sharp needle containers and strict instructions and alcohol swabs and this crazy protocol that I'm expected to do at home.
“整个机构怎么会让这种事发生？是谁培训了她们？谁觉得这没问题？我被寄回家包裹，里面装着锋利的针头容器、严格的说明书、酒精棉片，还有我在家被要求做的这种疯狂的方案。”
They make you double check things. Are there puncture marks? And I'm like, did I really spend more time following directions at home for hormone shots? Like, where were they?
“她们让你反复确认。有针孔吗？我心想，我真的花在家里遵守荷尔蒙注射说明的时间比她们还多吗？她们在哪里？”
I think my immediate reaction was, how could this happen at Yale? Why wasn't there a better system in place to prevent it or detect it when it was happening and respond? Why wasn't our pain listened to?
“我想我当时的第一反应是，这怎么会发生在耶鲁？为什么没有更好的制度来防止它，或者在发生时检测到并做出反应？为什么我们的疼痛没有被倾听？”
The women wonder about the system that failed them, but there's something very intimate and human that they are wondering about, too.
女性们对让她们失望的体制感到疑惑，但她们也对一些非常亲密和人性化的东西感到好奇。
We were notified that it was a nurse. We didn't have the name of the nurse in that original letter. And so it's sort of racing through your mind, like, well, which nurse? Because you build such a strong relationship with these people. And you see them so often. And you trust them and build a relationship.
“我们被告知那是一个护士。在那封原始信件中我们没有那个护士的名字。所以你的脑子里会飞速闪过，‘那么，是哪个护士？’因为你和这些人建立了如此牢固的关系。你经常见到她们。你信任她们并建立了关系。”
And so you're thinking like, well, which nurse could this have been? And then you're showing up, and OK, who's not here anymore? Who's gone? And just trying to figure out who it was.
“所以你会想，那么，这可能是哪个护士？然后你出现，好吧，谁不在了？谁走了？只是试图搞清楚那是谁。”
The patients know what happened. They're about to find out who did it. That's next.
患者们知道发生了什么。她们即将发现是谁做的。接下来就是这个。
Susan Burton. As Susan said in the show, Yale declined to answer any of her questions about what happened in this case or about what they've done to address the issues that it raises. But they did send her a statement that they've sent to other journalists. It states, quote, "Yale deeply regrets the distress suffered by some of its patients." It says that Yale alerted law enforcement about the, quote, "diverted pain medication." And it says that Yale Fertility Center, quote, "also reviewed its procedures and made changes to further oversight of pain control and controlled substances."
苏珊·伯顿。正如苏珊在节目中所说，耶鲁拒绝回答她关于本案中发生的事情或她们为解决由此引发的问题所做工作的任何问题。但她们确实发给她一份声明，这也是她们发给其他记者的声明。声明写道，引用：“耶鲁对部分患者遭受的痛苦深感遗憾。”它表示，耶鲁向执法部门通报了“被挪用的止痛药物”。并表示，耶鲁生育中心，“也审查了其程序，并进行了修改，以进一步加强对疼痛控制和受控物质的监督。”
You can get other episodes of The Retrievals wherever you get your podcasts. If you're a New York Times subscriber and you haven't tried their audio app yet, you really should check it out. You can find The Retrievals on there. Later episodes of the show cover the criminal case and the judge's decision, which is fascinating, really fascinating and very telling in its own way. The way this plays out feels very meaningful.
你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听《取卵》的其他剧集。如果你是《纽约时报》的订户，还没试过她们的音频应用，你真该看看。你可以在上面找到《取卵》。该节目的后续剧集涵盖了刑事案件和法官的决定，这非常引人入胜，非常令人着迷，而且以其独特的方式非常具有说明性。这件事的发展方式感觉非常有意义。
And of course, like Susan said, there's way more about the nurse who took the fentanyl, who, the patients learn, had been a fertility patient herself. So presumably, she understood the procedure that all of them went through and understood the stress and the feelings that anybody has during it and how they might feel getting it without anesthesia.
当然，正如苏珊所说，关于偷芬太尼的那位护士还有更多故事，患者们了解到，她自己也曾是一名生育治疗患者。所以推测，她理解所有患者经历的手术，也理解任何人在手术期间感受到的压力和情绪，以及她们在没有麻醉的情况下接受手术可能会有的感受。
["CAN'T BE TOO CAREFUL" BY JENNAH BELL]
The Retrievals is produced by Susan Burton and Laura Starecheski. It's edited by Laura Starecheski with Julie Snyder. Additional editing from Miki Meek, Katie Mingle, and me. Fact-checkers, Ben Phelan and Caitlin Love. Original score composed by Carla Pallone. Music supervision, sound design, and mixing by Phoebe Wang. Special thanks to Lisa Schuman, Calvin Hocker, Katie Fuchs, Kiley Silver, Dr. Marcelle Cedars, Dr. Maggie Smith, and Sam Dolnick.
《取卵》由苏珊·伯顿和劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基制作。由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基与朱莉·斯奈德共同剪辑。额外的剪辑来自米基·米克、凯蒂·明格和我。事实核查员，本·费伦和凯特琳·洛夫。原创配乐由卡拉·帕隆作曲。音乐监制、音效设计及混音由菲比·王完成。特别感谢丽莎·舒曼、卡尔文·霍克、凯蒂·福克斯、凯莉·西尔弗、马克塞尔·塞达斯医生、玛吉·史密斯医生以及萨姆·多尔尼克。
Bim Adewunmi, Mike Comite, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney put together this episode of our show. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
比姆·阿德温米、迈克·科米特、阿拉·穆斯塔法、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼共同制作了这一集节目。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播交换台（PRX）提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到这里，带来更多《This American Life》的故事。
["CAN'T BE TOO CAREFUL" BY JENNAH BELL]